what's going on guys x-men apocalypse
number one at the box office but
critical reviews have been a little bit
negative audience reviews a little up
and down and it earned less in its
opening weekend then x-men Days of
Future past some people are asking is
this franchise broken one person
believes it is one person who's been on
this show before to fix broken
franchises let's welcome back our
resident fixer Nick Mundy hello yes is
bearable that was adorable oh man it's
been a while yeah uh but I saw a movie
this weekend that brought out the ire
I love the x-men before the run starts
getting old [ __ ] cakes on me
I love the x-men x-men x-men to Braille
ass was pretty good yeah Matthew Vaughn
fine work yes should have stayed on it
Days of Future past him oh I like to
them like sure but apocalypse that's
what was a boring retread garbage
nothing of a movie wow yeah wrong word
it was from a strong man and carry this
table from the kitchen I went in with
lowered expectations and I came out
liking it but you had a different
viewing experience than me and that
echoes the viewing experience of many
people so Nick I want to hear from you
you want to fix a movie you want to fix
a movie now Nick let's fix up and movie
guitar solo
all right Nick we're fixing the x-men
what's the first step number one new
director how which movie was it where
Professor X got kidnapped which movie
wasn't where cerebro was used by the
villain to try to kill off half of
humanity which movie was it where
Professor X and Magneto had differences
of philosophy Magneto then killed a
bunch of people and that Professor X
forgave him anyway all right so there's
there some redundancies there's some
recurring themes you know it shout out
to Bryan Singer for getting people to
pay you to make the same movie four or
five different times I never walked into
a movie where I was spoiled just by
watching the other movies in the series
singer is basically turned the x-men
franchise into Bon Jovi he's just trying
to recreate the genius from the first
two albums and then just do it over and
over again and then what you get is it's
my life Nick I love that your references
are up to speed
no was interesting is when Matthew
Vaughn did first class it felt like a
breath of fresh air there was new blood
pumping into the franchise and it was
really really fun sure Days of Future
past was decent it was good people liked
it I get it but use sentinels and Peter
Dinklage even I couldn't that movie up
but he screwed up Oscar Isaac he turned
Isaac Isaac into like this blue Smurf I
hope you like what he's got planned for
the next x-men I'm sure it's gonna take
place in the 90s for some reason I bet
magneto uses cerebro to take over
Woodstock 99 festival while Quicksilver
runs really slow to a Smash Mouth song
quick okay now that I say it now I kind
of want that now like don't you want to
see Quicksilver running to hey now
you're an all star get your game on go
play now yeah yeah number two all new
x-men all of them yes and don't get me
wrong
like I love Fassbender McCoy like McAvoy
yes James McAvoy so Nick we're talking
about the core x-men here mystique
Professor X Magneto if we're not using
these characters who do you want to see
the x-men
we've seen them old and new we've done
everything we can do with them let's get
cannonball
let's get Domino let's get armor hell
let's get Dazzler Dazzler yeah the pop
artist uh mutant I just don't want to
see another movie about Eric and Charles
playing chess again but that's the
conflict yeah we've seen the
like nine times over and over and over
again there see friends they need a
breakup we went from that dudes who look
like they were about to 69 each other to
chess players I'm tired of it
what about gambit the gambit so Nick you
want all new characters how are we gonna
incorporate them I'm glad you asked
friend it's like you knew what I was
gonna say who number three
restart the universe but we just kind of
reboot it we just restarted every yeah
and you know what know what know what
happened
they've rebooted it like twice now three
times the continuities [ __ ] at the end
of your precious Days of Future past yes
Wolverine is rescued by mystique posing
as William Stryker
she has their eyes you know they flash
okay remember that but in this movie
blame Stryker actually has Wolverine
captured and he's doing the whole life
yeah weapon a thing that we've seen a
hundred times they said everything like
got reset but they're not even paying
attention to their own rules and it's
creating a confusing cluster of a movie
this is why prequels and in-between
quibbles
and quack holes several of those weren't
things yet okay I can starting to see it
but Nick this is a tough sell how do you
plan to get people on board with this
hell I'm glad you asked number four you
kill Wolverine what yes the best way to
show that we're not screwing around
we're starting over like grown-ups yeah
it's by killing the most beloved star
from the franchise I know hey it's tough
I got literally kill him yes chop off
his dick and his head in his arms and
his legs but why kill him why not just
write him out because I don't trust the
x-men folk to not use Wolverine in some
[ __ ] down the road like Wolverine
was so ham-fisted in this last movie it
made no goddamn sense instead of it like
having a scene with the young x-men that
would show their grit that would show
their worth
let's get Wolverine out here kill a
bunch of people and then walk through
with his death it was a little bit of a
get-out-of-jail-free I know he's like oh
here's a fisting there's a fist Inc well
it's this Wolverine into this looks this
Wolverine into the movie yeah I know if
that imagery is necessary but I
understand the point Nick what do you
got next number five going to space the
x-men have always been about bringing
different people different walks of life
different powers
humans mutants alike together that was
Charles Xavier is dream to bring people
together share of all legs and it was a
wonderful beautiful message mm-hmm but
um earth is ruined
let's humans are bad let's go into space
I think humans are pretty cool some of
them are yeah I'm not great okay a great
and the x-men have a history of being in
space yeah yeah you just don't have to
like there's the Shiar
there's lilandra the chick Professor X
used to bone
Scott Summers dead Cyclops his dad was a
space pirate one of the starjammers
there's an alien species that like just
likes to eat
I pulled the brood there's mojo this
like guy who watches TV across the
universe and he sets up American
Gladiator esque battles throughout the
world with different like alien species
yeah [ __ ]
mojo play by Steve new Chevy captures
the x-men and they got a running man
throughout the movie and then kick some
ass then eventually like you know you
know what mojo out on his own dick I
like running man I like the at you sell
me on space a little bit here Yeah right
huh like you were here and I was like
down here you got me like a couple rungs
up the ladder there a failure of
humanity to overcome our differences and
mojo we got a movie so you ready for the
next hop take lying it up lay it on us
Nick you ready for some clickbait sure
number six let Marvel take over all
right that's just like pie in the sky
everyone wants to see sure universe
where you can bring in the Avengers and
the x-men and the Fantastic Four and
spider-man yeah they're slowly taking
riding Marvel's going to start taking
over all the movies they'll take over
Star Wars and DC and the short circuit
franchise and police academy
Kate Leopold series they're all gonna be
the Marvel Universe they have a full
plate okay Kevin Feige guys I'm impotent
you've got a Tesla just filled with
infinity just here's the thing I think
everybody salivates over a world where
the Avengers and x-men could be woven
together and have some kind of yeah so
let's do storyline so why not all right
just sold me fine
- Nick is that it yeah number seven
number seven put the rock in it no Nick
we talked about bao's like but hold on
add something clever he's playing
himself
Nick I like that I'm gonna piggyback
that the rock is in it he plays himself
but he has a mutation which is
off-the-charts charisma you're way
better than me
okay so Nick there are people out there
who really liked apocalypse and who
think the franchise does not need to be
fixed what would you say to them that I
might be total [ __ ] it's just one
man's opinion
and if you have a differing opinion you
should
it doesn't matter like I really like the
movies soap dish not everyone likes the
movie soap dish if you agree with me
great and if you don't that's cool too
it stuttered weird opinions like that
that make the world organic but if I
have a different opinion than meet you
it's not me telling you your mother's a
piece of [ __ ] it's not
but then again soap dish is pretty great
uh what do you think about Nick's pitch
to fix the x-men does the x-men even
need to be fixed let us know in the
comments section below I want to thank
my main man the real deal Nick
Mundy oh I thank you sir Nick what's
coming up on Monday Night Raw more
shenanigans more stupid silly crap check
him out a Monday Night Raw I'm Hal rod
Nick hit me up on Twitter thanks for
watching bye bye you'd watch the x-men
bring classic storylines to life mission
accomplished money okay like the Phoenix
saga that was so much better than x3
Days of Future past that's as good as
Days of Future past